I have no lack of respect
for The Architects and people that are
out here what I get to is WTC I've seven
I've always it's always been hard for me
to believe wtc7 and what you've
described there I mean the British
broadcasted a half hour early before it
actually went down there's all these
things around wtt7 that causes a
fair-minded person just to sit back and
go wow wait a minute and so that that's
always there and I appreciate your
evidence I'd like to ask you something
you know Architects get consulted not
just to design you know impa to design
the most amazing buildings out there but
also to get rid of them
and they say hey we're going to take
down this ancient sport stadium and they
know they talk to the structural
engineers to find the key sure columns
sure but beams in the building too yes
Target you this is your world and I'm
not you know testifying against that but
the structural engineers and Architects
go hand in hand because the architect
brings you these beautiful designs the
structure engineer tells you if it can
come true with all the stuff that we
have to work with these days right and
the permits and the code and everything
you have to go through so
wouldn't you ask you get to a point it's
like when the police see massive frauds
or massive thefts the first thing the
police always say is where's the crew
who could have pulled this off and they
have a feeling about what organizations
or people have the kind of brains clout
intelligence access and that's good
police work to figure out okay who could
have robbed the museum that says who's
the crew this wasn't rookies and they
start asking themselves these questions
did you and these and these other
architects who know Structural Engineers
I know their Structural Engineers are
part of these three thousand signatures
right over 100 of them didn't you ever
get to the point and this isn't the
speculation to say wow what kind of a
crew this would taken and wouldn't some
of you said hey I was part of the
Kingdom being torn down in Seattle boy
the crew was like as a matter of fact
that one of the technical explosive
loaders who brought down the Kingdome is
in our documentary 911 explosive
evidence
demolition because that was a flawed
building by the way and it had to come
down in a very special way because it
was actually a dangerous building I read
a little bit about that so it's
interesting that one of those people was
there didn't you guys get to a point and
say wow where's the crew you know who
knows enough about this to do it not
merely foreign agents that worked with
an elevator company inside wasn't there
a thinking about this oh yeah in fact
Kevin how do you get rid of them because
remember Oswald I don't know that but
Kevin Ryan documents in his book another
19 suspects he lays them out for you and
their connections to nist who has
connections to Nano thermite it's it's
pretty incredible Kevin Ryan is one of
the major researchers uh in in the
country on this David Ray Griffin's
written 14 books on the subject which
fingers where did those gentlemen who's
responsible sorry to interrupt you but
you made a point there and I want to dig
into it so okay that's a possible crew
where did those those where did that
crew come from
that was you're talking about the
explosives loaders no no the first you
said seven Ryan another 19 suspect
correct where did those 19 come from
these are top individuals including uh
CEOs of corporations in the World Trade
Center who's who's uh many of whose uh
people were moved out of the World Trade
Center prior to 9 11 interestingly some
others were sacrificed so in fact uh uh
Canter Fitzgerald up there uh and whole
company and in in uh the the floors that
were hit by the airplanes he documents
that five floors above and below roughly
uh in the North and South Towers were
retrofitted with uh fireproofing
upgrades in the year or so before 9 11.
uh so was that an opportunity to place
uh fluid applied Nano thermite because
we know it's fluid because it's dual
layered red and gray and they're in
these tiny chips that we talked about
being peer-reviewed in the Bentham open
chemical physics journal called active
thermitic materials in the World Trade
Center dust so there he he he he invites
us to look at some of these uh
characters uh who and in fact um the the
the the the warden if you will of Iraq
uh did I didn't forget his name uh
uh he Paul Bremer was um brought on with
the CEO of one of these corporations in
the in the World Trade Center uh brought
on the day after 9 11 to finger Osama
bin Laden uh and then he's made the uh
the Iraq uh
leader if you will then the the
there's a word for that
um
so he's in charge of of the
Reconstruction and after we invade Iraq
so anyway he's a very suspicious
individual they're they're numerous
mayor Giuliani has his fingers all over
this Cheney uh was put in charge of the
tripod to exercise which brought
hundreds and hundreds of of State local
and government officials uh to Pier 92
in New York uh and in a drill the day
before 9 11. and guess what when
building seven went down all of the
responsibility was transferred over to
that
set of operatives an agency leaders who
took over the the the follow-up if you
will to the attacks uh Mr Gage did you
understand did you just say Giuliani had
his finger all over this as well as
Cheney did you just say that many people
have fingered them
specifically as what as involved in the
planning and execution and the cover-up
of these attacks are you one of the
people that believe Rudy Giuliani and
even Dick Cheney were involved in it
sure I believe that really because I
have heard enough about it for instance
so you believe Rudy Giuliani played a
part in 9 11. America's mayor on 9 11
was the person the culprit he had to be
oh really yeah please explain so and
there are people who have researched his
complicity for one he had foreknowledge
of the buildings the Twin Towers coming
down and said we got noticed that
they're going to come down well wait a
minute what about the 400 and 343
firefighters they didn't get notice that
the building was coming down so they
could get out of there only he had it
this is on so what are the chances that
Rudy Giuliani had a major part in 9 11.
that's very high very high yeah Richard
can I ask so I don't know a question
here I don't know how you because I was
asked to do the research it's going to
help you Adam so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]